[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Lucca Nate here at the altar boys
YouTube channel and today we are doing
another survival camping video you sat
in aid we're doing frontiersman style
surviving we're here in the old-growth
forests of Virginia and we've got our
possibilities bags ok these little these
little leather satchels here I have
everything we need to survive you got
yours yeah I do
some toilet paper some paracord
marshmallows and hot chocolate headlight
oh he gets a headlamp hand warmers in
case he gets cold at night and a little
tinfoil know you like your you like your
possibilities bag yeah it's cool
yeah there you go perfect neat size all
right these little leather bags are
called possibility bags and everything
you can need you can put right in these
little sturdy leather satchels and let
me show you what's in mine so inside
this is my fire-starting kit and I'll
show you more about what's inside that a
little bit later and I've got some flour
some spices and I've got some oatmeal in
here
and everything we need to cook our next
several meals is in here as well as a
little bit of fishing line other than
old bags we have a few other things
Nathan brought this along we're going
hobo style camping here apple and orange
anew and a far as sleeping bag intents
are concerned we got one wool blanket
between the two of us yeah so we explore
a little bit find a good spot to camp
and then you'll see about maybe catching
some fish yeah all right let's do it
so if you're building a survival shelter
and you need like shingles to make it
waterproof this is a really great way to
do that hey here's another one over here
take this take this tree out look at
this yeah that's a twisty tree yeah nice
and flat nice and dry okay well why
don't you lay down and find the spot
that you think is the softest and do you
want to make it a little softer here
watch this I'll see a trick
go over there and grab the corners of
the blanket maybe you can pick up all
these leaves get them over here
[Music]
there we go its mother nature's beanbag
chair you know the older I get the less
I worry about staying warm at night and
the more I worry about my back and so
having something soft to sleep on makes
a huge difference but I don't like
sleeping straight on leaves because they
poked and the itch and there's bugs in
there and stuff so if you can throw a
blanket on top of a pile of leaves ain't
too bad at all oh yeah there's a little
spider with the pig's head there you go
you want me cut it up for you you like
your Apple yeah I love walking through
these old-growth forests but they're
kind of barren because there's no
undergrowth at all there's no berries
there's no herbs and there's not much in
the way of wildlife because there's
nothing to sustain them in this
particular forest I haven't seen any
sign of beer I haven't seen any
squirrels so I usually go catch a fish
all right we're gonna try our hand at
doing a little fish in here but we're
gonna need some bait let's see if we can
find any earth
and normally you just scratch the leaf
litter a little bit get down to the
soggy stuff and you'll see earthworms
but it's so dry right now that you get
down to the soil and it's still dry so
the earthworms if they are here are way
down deep I need to find someplace soggy
there's a little moisture oh look at
this look what I just found is that cool
or in the right spot
whoa whoa hello hello I found one Nate
nice one
I've been turning over a lot of logs and
digging up a lot of mud and I found one
worm
hey check this out oh-ho a little piece
of cane or bamboo that it's gonna be
useful
there all right the little piece of
sliver I put on the end of my line it's
called a fish couch it's a primitive
fish hook the fish swallow it and as
soon as you put tension on the line the
points sticking to the side of the
fish's throat so if it goes into its
stomach or throat you've got a pretty
decent chance of catching it but you
can't set the hook it's not like a
fishing Clark you just gotta wait until
they swallow it and then gently pull the
fish up and it's either in his gut or
it's not and you lose a lot of bait this
way but it works best with bluegill
sunfish that sort of thing so that's
what we're trying to do now I am
targeting panfish crappie bluegill
sunfish that sort of thing you want to
find them
look for a little bit of deep water with
some snags and overhanging trees that's
your jam right there
there you go there you go yeah he's
pulling it bite yeah oh it's so tiny I
got a fish uh-huh there we go a little
green sunfish now they've got bigger
mouths than bluegill do compared to
their body size so he was able to get
this thing down but let's see if we can
get him off the hook once the fish
swallows a gouge often the only way to
get it out is to cut him open there's
not really a lot of catch and release
with fish gouges let's see oh I got it I
still have the worm you think we should
eat him we hold him closer to the camera
he'll be a bigger meal there we go the
world's tiniest three you're here hold
on to a pen when you're fishing in
backcountry places you really got to be
quiet and stealthy when you're fishing
in city ponds it don't matter
it's like people who live in the big
city they don't hear the traffic and the
city noise it's all white noise to them
but if you're from the country and it's
quiet out and you hear anything unusual
it really sticks out it's the same thing
with the fish it's so quiet here that
any noise sticks out oh you know bite
well I'm getting a bite oh oh there we
go
[Music]
oh you got my world my fish girl just
broke so I'm gonna really quick make
another one the bamboo piece I left it
way over there so I'm just gonna grab
any old piece of hardwood I think this
is a little oak branch it should work
just fine I have spent a lot of time
fishing with fish gouges and a couple
years ago I really obsessed over it and
I made him out of wood I made him out of
bone and I really wanted to catch a
catfish with a fish gouge and I burned
through probably 15 blue gills
and got lots and lots and lots of hits
and never once got one to really
properly hook up and what I discovered
was that you waste so much bluegill meat
trying to catch a catfish that you're
just better off eating the bluegill then
trying to use them as bait to catch
something bigger for whatever reason
it's just I never got it to work with a
catfish that's how it is usually in
survival situations you're better off
eating a whole bunch of little animals
and plants rather than trying to spend a
whole bunch of energy chasing a moose or
a buffalo or something all right there
we go got another fish couchant honestly
I kind of like this one a little better
it's a little hair larger size is really
important with fish gouge is too small
and it won't set too big it won't go
down so you got to make it just right
check it out if the blue gills are
bedding I can see you're out in the
middle there's all these dimples the
size of dinner plates all over it looks
like the surface of the Moon just all
these craters and in the center there's
a pair of blue gills in there and that's
where they're making their nests so the
blue gills not many of them are gonna be
in the shallows if they're out spawning
there they're gonna be out there on
those beds unfortunately I can't reach
them from here so it's part of the
seasonality of everything you know
there's time and a season to catch blue
gills and there's a time in this season
to gather acorns and a season to get
morels and stuff and you've got to kind
of know what's in season in your
location
well we fish for about 30 minutes and
managed one very tiny fish so we weren't
skunked and it was a decent little demo
but that's my experience with fishing
with fishing gouges just takes a lot
more time and effort
I really didn't need to bring a hatchet
on this trip but this is one of my
projects over the winter and it's kind
of sentimental I I really loved it so I
brought it along perfect that's what we
needed
you tired Nathan is that comfy all right
all right let me show you my fire
starting kit here okay inside I have a
bunch of shredded jute this stuff is
basically twine then I rub on a belt
sander and it makes these fine shavings
that just go up like gasoline absolutely
wonderful stuff and deeper down in here
I have a little bit of char cloth in a
dime bag and I've got a steel striker
and a little piece of Flint char cloth
is basically charcoal eyes cloth now
what I'm gonna do and I'm gonna pinch
that char cloth right up against the
sharp edge right there because that's
where I hope the sparks are gonna go and
I'm gonna grip my striker and we're
gonna go
like that where that what I do with my
yeah that's how you make fire with
traditional flint and steel right there
put that back in my little can all right
let's get Dinner started I've got some
olive oil I've got some bread flour I've
got salt and pepper a little bit of
honey some butter add some oil I'm gonna
add a pinch of salt I'm gonna add some
butter into the dough
all right we're gonna make a very basic
flatbread and cook it on this rock over
here and you don't want to add too much
water you want it so that the dough
doesn't stick to your hands because if
it sticks to your hands it'll stick to
the rock tiniest fish ever
all right let's cook him up all right
that's feeling good get that butter
melting on here you know put some honey
for our little fish we're gonna give him
a little salt just gonna rip off his
spines try to make a meal out of this
now if I didn't have honey butter
flatbread I would not throw the guts the
way I just popped the whole thing in my
mouth but I do have it so I can afford
to be selective mmm little bones it was
one one mouthful let's do round two oh
yeah this is a different type of
survival camping we're packing really
light we're eating simple foods we're
not building any sort of shelter really
this is for tracking cross-country and
good weather you know you need to go
somewhere on foot it's gonna take a
couple days it looks sunny and nice you
go and do this sort of thing and this
this is real frontier style
cross-country survival camping and it's
kind of fun all right buddy you got
dessert there
my cousin fire but I'm just bored out
yes we caught little toad like IQ well
I'm gonna let him go okay well the sun's
gonna set on us appear really quick so I
gotta do a couple things to tidy up
before he gets dark first off I'm gonna
take my shirt off because I'm really
sweaty and I want it to dry and I want
to get dry before the Sun sets and it
gets cold okay the other thing is I got
to pick up all of our stuff that we
scattered all over and make sure it's
all put away so I can find it in the
dark it's getting dark and I promised
Nathan we would watch some movies before
we went to sleep so I'm gonna bust out
my phone I downloaded the new spongebob
movie yeah well the Sun is set and the
movies over and the bugs are out to keep
the spiders out you know let's go to bed
I'll see you guys in the morning
while I kept Nathan up late last night
so I'm gonna let him sleep in as long as
he can and I'm gonna get breakfast ready
all right so I got some leftover butter
leftover honey and salt raisin and
steel-cut oatmeal so it's different than
the instant oats you're used to this
stuff tastes so much better oh there we
go
steel-cut oatmeal with raisins butter
and honey only way this could be better
is if I had some cream to put on it
there we go carved myself a little spoon
well I made a fire cooked breakfast ate
it and Nathan is still out like a light
that boy can sleep anywhere let me show
you something I got with me this Garmin
inReach mini it's a GPS device but it's
also a whole lot more than that
this allows my cellphone to send text
messages allows my wife to track my
location while I'm out here without cell
service and it's just a nice little has
this SOS button I can flip up the safety
cap hit that button and it puts me in
touch with first responders but it's
also just nice to be able to text my
wife and her to be able to go online and
see where I'm at when I don't have cell
service so it just takes a lot of
anxiety out of things and it's just a
big safety plus because if something
happens out here I can get help
immediately hold it let me get that way
and look I even carved a spoon for you
well did you have anything crawl on you
in the night I had a couple ants get on
my face last night
well Nathan did you have fun well I hope
you guys enjoyed watching this video as
much as we did making this video hey if
you want to see more camping and
survival videos we've got a ton of them
don't we Nathan no we'll put links to
all of that in our video description
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
yeah if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that belt like you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]